i have a hard time finding optimism
lately you're one of the few
places i turn when i'm feeling really
down oh that means so much to me
bridgette i'll go to your twitter feed
and be like i know this will be positive
here's the thing bridgette i mean like
and this is one of the strange tensions
in my brief political existence
so i ran for president on a very
optimistic idea of universal basic
income but it was built on a very
negative case which is oh by the way
ai's coming and it's kind of blast away
like a ton of jobs and we already did it
to those guys we're gonna do it to you
too eventually
um so that there's like a real
um
you know juxtaposition or it's like and
the other thing is someone said to me
it's like hey yang you can present some
very distressing [ __ ] in a
matter-of-fact away that doesn't make me
you know super sad and i'm like oh good
well you know this is um so
the situation right now is
awful
uh our political
landscape terrible like generationally
bad
um and so it's not like i'm unmindful of
these things i mean that the fact is if
i thought that things were going to go
well
i would be doing something else right
you know what i mean
like so i'm very cognizant of just how
knee deep and [ __ ] we are and the and
the shit's you know threatening to go
well above knee level
right
but but now i'm in a position where
maybe i can help maybe i can contribute
something positive i see a path
and it does consist of what you're
describing with this look politically
homeless
yeah like potential energy let's just
come together raise our hands say look
um we
want something different
uh and the forward party is a way to
achieve something different at a minimum
it's a way to say get off my back i'm
not donating to either of your
candidates
[Laughter]
i'm just going to make my home over here
and try and fight for a process where
new parties can emerge
[Music]
[Music]
on this week's podcast a really great
and fascinating conversation with the
comedian and writer bridget fedesy
bridget has had a journey that you will
not believe i learned so much from her
coming up today on forward
[Music]
hey there bridgette and i'm walking in
you're walking in
i'm so excited to have you you're you're
like the mascot for the politically
homeless
yes i'm building a giant homeless
shelter called the forward party uh it's
i mean heck we should be
the majority of the country
it's like a very very large public
shelter yeah it's it's interesting
because i
i saw when you first came out with the
book and you were announcing that you
were leaving the democratic party and
kind of moving
you got piled on with i i
i left the left i guess um probably in
2017 is when i got a little bit
disillusioned or pushed
wherever to the center
and the same exact things that they were
all saying about you that you're a
grifter that
all the names all of the things and i'm
like this happens to every single person
who who manages to find their way to
independence well bridgette tell me
about your story because
um i've heard this from a couple of
other people but
um no offense or anything but like you
know i'm kind of a political figure
so i feel like if if you were to go be
like people being mean to you just
seemed so strange to me oh yeah well
because it's um
i
i think it was just i mean they're mean
to anybody who really and i was like you
said or implied not like a big deal at
all it was really just somebody who i
was writing for playboy i got kind of
i started just seeing things on the left
that i started calling out i'm a
comedian
i'm a writer i just was like i'm not
supposed to you know be loyal to one
side but i think because so tell me more
what were you calling out bridget like
what what where did this begin
it really started in like 2015 2016. so
i was writing a playboy but then when
i saw kind of the rise of trump and a
lot of the hypocrisy around the way
particularly women on the left were
talking about
you know melania
and ivanka just judging their appearance
their clothes i was like i thought we
weren't supposed to do this you know
i don't i i think if we if we have
principles and don't apply them equally
there i always say if you don't apply
your principles to people who disagree
with your principles of garbage and
that was the beginning of the end and
then i stumbled into this space unlike
you
who you know obviously went into this
with intention
i i'm very much um
got caught in the crossfire of the
culture wars is really the best way to
describe it
but i think i represent like the average
i always say i'm a member of the [ __ ]
majority i'm like
i was just a worker i was a waitress
trying to make ends meet forever i i
know very much what it's like to have i
think you said in your book like
the boot of that financial insecurity i
still
am
amazed when i go to my bank account and
take out money and there's
more money in my bank account still or
even have enough money to be able to
take out i mean
i just was i was living really close to
the edge for so long well into my 30s
being freelance
waiting for people to pay me
i still don't invoice like i have this
weird thing where i don't invoice
people because it's like my savings
even though i have savings now but it's
still this old kind of um
scarcity mentality that i live with and
i think anyone who has been you know
financially under stress under duress
and that's why i'm so interested to talk
to you because i think
i do i ended up in this space and then i
just kind of became a voice for people
who
were confused disillusioned
and really have no trust in the system
no trust in politicians a lot of the
people who
are in my little fantasy community my
subscriber community they voted for you
you know they're
i think that you are the politician that
probably best rep
comes closest to representing that those
feelings of frustration with everything
and i don't know those invoices are
called accounts receivable
like my accounts receivable are my
savings account
but i need some money i'm gonna
invoice
yeah it might take 90 days to get it
um that plan doesn't always go according
to the way i would
think but
yeah there's a lot that i was reading
your book too and i'm like i don't
understand anything it was kind of
i just sometimes feel like
even ubi which i understand the concept
of i'm like please explain it to me
like i'm
in kindergarten
or like i'm in high school and how
i understand the concept but i don't
necessarily understand how it works in
practice and i think like you said we
got to see that
with a pandemic you know people getting
these checks
um
although i still think it's probably
going to cause a lot of you know debt
and whatnot
i'm not sure about
it
i don't know that we can just write
checks like that forever but um
yeah that that's one of my big questions
is how how does this work and is there
like a cap is it like people under a
does everybody get this no matter what
their income is under my proposal
everyone
who is 18 or over gets a thousand bucks
a month regardless of your circumstances
and
uh we saw versions of it we're still
seeing versions of it
uh and
it's been by and large great
uh the child tax credits helped a lot of
people and families who are in tough
tough circumstances the stimulus and
cash relief checks
were generally very very good
to the extent that we've seen inflation
one of the things i try and walk people
through bridget is that the cares act
authorized 2.2 trillion dollars in
savings it's a big number whatever it's
not you know but the thing that um most
people don't realize is that 83 of that
money did not go to us like the stimulus
or the cash relief checks
were a smidgen of that 2.2 trillion
uh 83 of it went to banks airlines
pipes institutions just saying like hey
hey
um
make make sure your shareholders are
good make sure your balance sheets look
good uh and then people got a bit of a
dribble
and then you look up and say well
there's inflation in the economy it's
because of those checks it's like no no
no like that the checks were a very
small component of the money that got
pumped into the system
um so that that's one aspect that most
people don't realize
but i i do want to
uh return to your arc because i'm just
fascinated by it so you write an article
and you're like hey maybe we shouldn't
be mean to melania or vodka because i
thought our thing was not judging people
based upon their appearances and then
you got a reaction of some kind did you
write an article it was an online post
no i wrote an article part of the
problem with that was that again i
stumbled into the i was like waiting
tables as i mentioned i was i came out
to la to be an actress a way and a
comedian and a writer and
i was out here just grinding and for
years and
i started i got a job for playboy as a
sex columnist which i loved it was like
my dream job and
that was my first introduction to being
quote unquote very online i was not on
um i was on twitter but i was really
just around the comedians and trying to
see
how they use twitter and
um then and used it to kind of practice
writing jokes and then
i ended up
writing this piece
um a lot of my audience has heard this
story but i wrote this piece
women date [ __ ] because you're a
[ __ ]
and it was like
just about i always got this question
why do women date [ __ ] and
and so i i wrote a piece for playboy and
i thought maybe i would get some grief
from you know like the right wing or
like and everybody came after me the
men's rights activists came after me and
then feminists came after me because i
was using terms like real men and i was
not prepared for this like attack from
the left
and that was my first introduction into
terms like
oh god all of it i mean i knew nothing
and nothing and i was
35 years old when i stumbled into this
but i just wasn't online i didn't oh i i
oh i get this i get this so you're a
kind of a visitor to online culture and
then you put out some stuff that was you
know like
uh normal person speak uh and then you
got attacked for it oh god i didn't know
anything about internalizing patriarchy
toxic masculinity i had never heard any
of these terms i didn't go to college i
dropped out when i was a freshman and i
wasn't indoctrinated in any in any of
those respects and i was really just
it was surprising to me but then i got
swept up in the culture war because i
started noticing as i was more online i
started paying more attention to things
that i just really hadn't paid attention
to ever
i always thought and i still kind of
believe this my arc has really brought
me back to where i started which is that
politics were for rich people or really
poor people like i wasn't rich i was
just a working class i felt like i was
getting screwed on both ends and
that that was just the way it was i was
pretty blue collar and
i was i didn't really pay attention i
was very much just uh
i called factory settings just pull the
lever of whatever you had you know what
i was raised with i was raised a very
liberal in a liberal family like my
grandmother's very kennedy kind of
liberal and
so i didn't really think about it it was
like i say i was like being in a
self-driving car i just kind of and then
i looked up and i was like i'm not
anywhere where i thought i was and the
culture had shifted so much around me
that it was very disorienting and then i
started writing
um
i wrote a piece of trump's inauguration
actually trying to look at the bright
side of his election now people weren't
ready for this
kind of optimism
and it was crazy i shed just hundreds of
followers just for even the title of the
piece
and
i ended up because i was saying like
it's exposing everything like he he's
horrible
for our country
but he's exposing
so many of the things that are broken
and wrong
and
that was eye-opening and then i ended up
writing a piece called high-heeled
hypocrisy about exactly what i just was
mentioning to you and
i mind you as freelance writer so some
editor reached out and said hey we'll
take that piece because i said yeah i'll
write about the hypocrisy on the left
but no one will publish it because then
i started recognizing things that
weren't allowed like the sacred cows and
things that i couldn't say whether it
was in comedy or in
the sex column world or just on the left
in general and
they um it was the federalist
and i knew nothing about the federalists
or what it represented and so then i
posted it on my facebook and everyone
was like unsubscribe from your patreon i
mean it was like a whole thing i had no
idea so
i'm really an idiot that just kept
stumbling
very publicly into one disaster after
another and just trying to write my way
through it
so so when this happened and people were
like unsubscribe unsubscribe were you
like you know
what the heck is going on here or did it
pain you or hurt you or did you like
look up yeah what's like the natural
reaction yeah i mean it was hard because
i felt that i was you know no one likes
rejection i think this is the hardest
thing
and i feel like you've weathered it well
in terms of the way that when you came
out with the forward party and and i saw
a lot of that obviously much at a
much greater
level being directed at you
um higher yeah higher scale
visibility yeah a lot and more volume
obviously and um
you're trending and all this stuff
i see that it's um
it's
i think for me the hardest thing was
recognizing when i was being reactive
and not going
too far
it's easy to become reactive and go in
and you're like am i being reactive
because i'm being rejected or am i is
this
that is something that is something very
very powerful bridget that i'm not sure
people understand
is that if someone
pelts you with you know whatever
uh verbal rocks
like
it's very very natural for you to recoil
and then
um take on a
like an adversarial stance toward the
pelters you know i mean right like what
the heck are you doing and they'd be
like oh you all like there's something
wrong with you and then you you wind up
reacting right to your point which i
understand why people would do that it's
like you said very natural which is why
i get frustrated for instance after the
recent virginia elections when i was
like countdown to blaming white women
because inevitably but i'm i'm i want to
shake that
that's mildly funny
too i want to shake the democrats feel
like this isn't helpful you know you if
you want to win okay you can blame them
but that's still you're still putting
people in a position where they're
where they're going to feel defensive
you know like like f you it's hard and i
don't know that everyone has the
self-awareness to like pause and be like
am i being reactive and just for the
sake of being reactive
[Music]
it's the holiday season which means it's
a great time for a lot of people but you
know what honestly it's also a really
depressing time for a lot of people i
don't know maybe our lives aren't like
the movies maybe we're thinking about
people that aren't with us but in any
case right now is a great time to take
charge of your mental health to get the
professional help that a lot of us know
that we've kind of needed for a little
while don't put this on your friends and
family they have no idea what they're
talking about some of the times
instead you should use our sponsor
betterhelp.com
and there are professional therapists
who are trained and available to you
when you need them it's like mental
health
on call it's pretty amazing this is one
way that we can use the services of
today to actually improve our lives and
if you visit our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
yang you'll get 10 off your first month
join over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help help
calm
yang happy holidays let's make him happy
for real
[Music]
so then in the arc you i ended up
getting
asked because the right loves it when
there's like us
an apostate
yes
they'll be like come to us and they were
the only people who were asking me to
talk and i still wanted to get out and
say what i had to say
but then it became this thing of
being hyper aware of the fact that i
might be getting weaponized you know you
use being used essentially like a useful
idiot and
um
i mean i could tell so many stories i
was in a bathtub in washington dc just
crying after i did
this
i did an interview that was great
because i was a former heroin addict and
i was like i will talk to anybody about
recovery and i actually think the right
does not benefit from a lot of these
kinds of conversations because they're
such a reactive
media ecosystem that they're not
necessarily doing like
a lot of mental health and
um wellness kind of pieces
on their websites they're just not
exposed to as much of it as you are on
the left in our in in that ecosystem
and so i was i went on
um
i went on a podcast and then that night
uh there was like a whole thing in new
york with the proud boys and i was just
like am i a part of the problem you know
like
because a lot of things people would
accuse me of is like you're carrying
water for nazis your health you're only
helping the right wing you're only
helping these fascists and
i i didn't know enough about anything to
know that that might not be true i i was
always questioning is this true
so i don't know did you ever have any
doubt when you when you were kind of in
this i mean i'm curious like what led
you to your
what is your arc
i'll be very happy to share my arc
bridgette so
uh i
grew up in upstate new york and then the
suburb of new york city i went to school
in new england went to a very liberal
school
and
voted for clinton the second time bill
that is
no i'm in my 40s
i've been living in new york city for
my adult life and so being a democrat
seemed very natural
was not that involved my
exposure to politics was that i started
getting awards
during the obama administration
started meeting senators and members of
congress and the president and the
former president some other people as i
got cooler more or less like i started a
non-profit that did good work and so as
i got cooler i got invited to cool stuff
and so i'd meet these political figures
and i will admit to you that one of the
vibes i caught was like okay these
people are not really going to change
anything that important like they're
just kind of shaking my hand hanging out
congratulating doing
uh fundraisers and press junkets and
like that this is not the crew that's
going to somehow like take the ship and
turn it 90 degrees
[Laughter]
that's not in the cards uh and then
trump won in 2016 and i came to a full
stop and thought wow
this was
uh
this was to me a giant
uh
cry of actually either
uh anger or anguish you know it's like
either pain or anger um and i'd spent
six
and a half years working in the midwest
and the south i'd seen all these
communities that had disintegrated
frankly in the aftermath of getting rid
of manufacturing jobs there are some in
new england too like in northern new
hampshire yeah very different upstate
new york
yeah
uh and and so i thought well i need to
try and explain this to people and
i
wrote a book the war on normal people
and thought well i will run for
president on this set of ideas and i
figured even if i flopped i would still
advance
universal basic income and some other
big ideas i would explain the fourth
industrial revolution to people you and
i were both on the joe rogan podcast so
that was like a big opportunity for me
and i was running as a democrat i met
thousands of democrats i thought i was a
democrat but the the strange part is
that as i was running um i started to
feel like maybe i'm not like a fit for
this party like there there were um
there were some rituals going on where i
would speak to a democratic group and i
would speak in a way that i think which
is hey guys we
uh automated away four million
manufacturing jobs and now 30 of your
malls and retail stores are going to
close and eventually we're going to
automate the cars and trucks and it's
all you know just going to get worse and
worse
uh and uh because i wasn't speaking a
political language people had no idea
what to do it would be like this kind of
polite applause be like and i have no
idea what like how to react to what this
asian guy is saying
because i wasn't presenting it in
political speak uh and
political consultants would say to me
like hey you really need to politick it
up some right um so i ended up stumbling
into this political language that i
thought was the democratic language but
it turns out it was not the democratic
language
uh and then after my presidential
campaign ended i wrote a book
uh forward that tried to figure out why
shit's not working oh thank you bridget
i appreciate it did you enjoy the book i
did yeah i'm still i'm like the the meat
and potatoes of it i still am trying to
get my mind around i'm not gonna lie
um i'm not like an economist and so a
lot of the stuff in the middle i
i have to like pause and look things up
and
um but i love the beginning of your
story and i love to at the end where you
kind of outline what the forward party
is about and
uh just the things that need to be fixed
and i actually like really appreciate
how practical it is and and and how meat
and potatoes it is even if sometimes i
feel like i'm an idiot
well you're definitely not an idiot it
must be you know that the middle is
poorly written
no it's not poorly written
it's just
more um technical stuff about the the
economy and i'm just not it's that stuff
just doesn't
come naturally to me you know that
understanding how it all works does not
always come
it's not my second nature
well the big discovery i made when i was
writing this book bridget was that [ __ ]
is not going to work that the duopoly is
not designed to solve problems it's
designed to
anger us and inflame us and turn us
against each other and that's where
billions and billions of dollars of
political money and media incentives and
social media and the rest of it will
drive us
and so imagine running for president and
then coming to the conclusion that okay
this system is setting us up to
devolve and turn on each other and wind
up in civil war 2.0
so what is a reasonable way out and to
me the reasonable way out would be to
try and break up the duopoly and say
that we need certainly more than two
parties like two parties makes no sense
at all
right
that you couldn't make that argument as
a member of one party or the other
so then i naturally concluded okay i'm
going to leave the democratic party and
become an independent and then start a
third party movement that will
try and shift our primary system to
closed party primaries which by the way
disenfranchises like eighty percent of
americans in fact yes like if you're in
california and you're a republican you
might as well just forget about it not
sure and most of play there are parts of
california where you can compete but
there are other parts where it's a waste
of your time i'm in new york and if
you're an independent or republican
waste of your time obviously you know
like that like the democrats run this
this town
so
i concluded that okay i need oh that we
need to change the dynamic
and if you were to make a list of people
that would have a shot at changing the
dynamic i'm somewhere on that list um so
let me present to my country the case
that this duopoly is going to grind us
up and and destroy us and turn us
against each other and the rest of it i
uh and this is ridiculous bridget
because i've made this mistake gosh like
any number of times now i did not expect
there to be that much of a reaction
you should have consulted me
yeah i definitely should have
i could have warned you
though though when the reaction was
coming out
um i did not
feel bad about it like it kind of
verified some of my
thoughts where i thought okay this
country is really badly polarized 42
percent of americans think the other
side is evil or they're mortal enemies i
mean it's a recipe for disaster over
time
and then when i
said publicly hey i'm leaving the
democratic party to become an
independent uh getting attacked made me
feel like okay then i you know i was
correct
right but we're polarized and you know i
tried not to take anything people were
um
slinging at me personally i was just
like okay this is just the polarization
talking and
yeah
and if you look at it too
i thought i was relatively benign about
it like my statement upon leaving the
democratic party was not like oh you
know democrats suck this song it was
just like look like i think this is a
better way i can be of value and
conserve and i think we need a different
dynamic i thought it was like so
innocuous but the substance of it was
completely lost you know and people
would just like attack it on i don't
know like for whatever reason
um
it was it was
um but it was
encouraging in its own way and then i
did get some calls and texts from people
that i really admire and respect who
would say hey like you know
welcome the water's warm
here at
independent land
and uh i have really enjoyed being an
independent these past two months i
genuinely feel like you might have felt
this too and i tried to explain this to
folks earlier but like you feel like
uh like
a
set of glasses has come off your face
and then you see things differently like
i underestimated also
the impact of just filling out a form
and changing my voter registration from
democrat to independent i was like okay
i need to do this because it's just like
a formality but then when i did it all
of a sudden
my mindset shifted
my reading of news shifted
um like instead of thinking of it as us
i thought of as them
um and so when
you know democrats lost in virginia i
wasn't like we lost it was like oh they
lost
and it's been uplifting it's been
enlightening i genuinely think i see
things more clearly now than i did uh 10
weeks ago just because of that paperwork
it's wild it's black
yeah that i think there's well one of my
questions that came up right at the
beginning of your arc did you
did you
were you surprised by trump's win
i was surprised by trump's win because
i'm a numbers guy and so when you looked
at the numbers according to all the
surveys like hillary wins by a few
points in life right on
uh you know i i supported bernie in the
primary and then um voted for hillary in
the general so i was like okay hillary
wins life goes on um i was surprised yes
were you
i wasn't
i kept telling everybody that he was
gonna win out here which did not make me
popular right away and i even lost
friends for suggesting that he was gonna
win but i remember i went home
and i was in my very east coast um
family and a couple of people mentioned
that
i remember someone sat down with me and
they i thought they were joking when
they said they were voting for trump and
then they sat down with me
and they were like i'm just so [ __ ]
sick of the left talking down to me and
that stuck out so much and this was
right i had just been in london and
ireland on the heels of brexit which i
was obsessed with i was i was like this
is
this is happening here too this kind of
anger and these feelings of being left
behind or
being um the resentment that kind of
resentment vote
and when i started hearing that even in
places that were very liberal and from
family members that i was shocked to
hear it from i was i went came back to
l.a and i'm like we're missing something
you know something big
and then just seeing the temperature i
moved a lot as a
as a teenager and pre-teen every year
and a half so i spent a good part of my
middle school and high school in
minnesota and the midwest and i just
have still a lot of friends from the
midwest so
good for some of my best friends and
family members and just seeing how many
were
really excited about trump and kind of
openly excited for that change just
all of that information even though it
was anecdotal put together i just felt
like we weren't none of it was being
represented and i'm like no one's gonna
be honest we're not creating
any kind of ecosystem where people can
be honest about how they actually feel
because if they were they'd be called a
nazi or they'd be called a white
supremacist so why would anybody be
honest they're just going to go and vote
the way they want to vote and not tell
anyone because it was already causing so
much stress
in the families and i see this now
playing out like everything's been so
politicized and
now with covet and you you mentioned
this too in your book and i love that
chapter just about
how it's hurt you know the strain that
it's put on families within families
people who are pro-vaccine people who
don't want to get it there's
people being left out of family events i
read some article the other day that one
in four americans or something has
suffered some kind of falling out with a
family member and it's causing them
obvious distress
and that's sad to me you know i grew up
in a big huge family where everybody was
all over the political spectrum i have a
communist uncle in germany and my
grandparents were very clear about like
you don't
sure the cops came to a lot of drunken
family arguments but
they were very clear that you don't let
that you know
mess with family like that just isn't
something you let be come between you so
seeing that um already happening in 2015
was really unsettling i think that
process has really just only got worse
from what i i was hoping it would get
better
with biden but it just seems like it's
actually got worse
it's not getting better
i'm going to share something
that
i heard earlier
this week i talked to
a
woman who regularly polls voters
and has been pulling them for the last
five years
and when a trump voter talked to her
in 2016. they would say something like
look i've got a problem with trump like
i don't love some of the things he says
and does but i just can't stand hillary
and i'm voting for trump it was like uh
kind of like i'm voting for trump and
i'm just explaining it away by saying
that like this is a vote against the
other side
and uh with each successive focus group
over time now they don't hide anything
they're like like love trump hate the
others
right
and
they have kind of gone in for it there's
like no sheepishness
right
like anymore or like the the
desire to keep it to yourself the way
you're describing like is weaker
you know
they don't lie to pollsters anymore in
that way
[Music]
you know what we all like to do sleep we
do it almost a third of the time and we
don't pay enough attention to what we're
sleeping on by which i mean your
mattress helix sleep will send you a
personalized mattress just take two
minutes to complete and match your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why buy a
mattress made for
just any tom dick and harry or sally or
whoever you know what i mean make a
mattress
customized for you use some technology
the helix sleep quiz it's fast it's the
future
and you will be so glad i gotta say the
helix sleep mattress is the most popular
thing in my house
it was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pickup 2020 by gqn
wired magazine that's a pretty fun fun
task right just like testing mattresses
and helix sleep was the winner so go to
helixsleep.com yang take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life you
won't want to wake up no you should wake
up but you should wake up with a good
night's sleep and that's what
helixsleep.com will do for you helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com yang go to
helixsleep.com today
[Music]
i wrote this piece that went viral even
though
all these publishers were telling me
this audience doesn't exist but it was
the battle cry of the politically
homeless and i think i wrote this in
2017 or 2018 and talking about how
they're i felt this authoritarian creep
coming from both sides nobody likes to
hear this but i was feeling it on the
left around speech you know regulation
and what you could and couldn't say and
all of that and then on the right
obviously there's just um
the kind of despotic attitude of trump
at the time and that the cult of
personality around him is terrifying to
me just that demanding fealty from
everyone around you
and so
those two kind of forces
really are what pushed me to the middle
more than anything and i started an
email address i am politically homeless
at gmail.com and told people to kind of
write me their story i got
thousands of emails from people and
telling me their story of transition now
whether it was from the right to the
left from the left to the right
some anarchist who became radicalized
into voting somebody who hadn't it was
so many fascinating stories from all
types of people all walks of life and
then in 2020 i
kind of circled back and had people
write me right before the election about
how they were feeling were they hiding
their vote from their spouse
and the thing that struck me the most
was the people in 2016 who were maybe
reluctant or sheepish as you mentioned
voters of trump were
all in on trump or they regretted not
voting for trump in 2016. there was i
had so many hundreds of emails of people
who were saying um
exactly what you're mentioning and then
there were people who were
on the other side who had been voted for
trump and thought that he could like
hold it together and not be trump and
we're so disgusted by him that they're
like i'm voting blue all the way down i
don't care so it was interesting
i think every and i just had a really
interesting discussion with um this guy
jesse morton about radicalization and
hyper polarization and we were talking
about how everyone's being radicalized
yeah increasingly for sure
yeah so how how did your i mean did you
have any personal loss from your
announcement that you are leaving the
democratic party did you personal loss
in terms of relationships and friends
and people
or did it not really affect you that
much
i have
many many friends who are avid democrats
as you'd imagine because you know i've
traveled the country for the last number
of years running for president uh and
mayor as a democrat each time and so
yeah it's
put a cramp in a lot of those
relationships
uh i will say though that i see those
relationships as
kind of a hybrid between personal and
professional
like are there friends of mine who i
consider friends who called me and said
hey i'm not going to be friends with you
anymore like no i haven't really gotten
that
[Laughter]
you haven't been disowned or anything
yeah i mean certainly my parents could
give a [ __ ] i mean yeah i actually went
to my parents
because i talked about in the book how
i'm the son of immigrants and i have no
idea what my parents thought about
american politics so i actually went to
my parents was like hey
my mom
um hey mom did you like
vote
and please don't judge my mom but the
answer was no she was like i didn't
really understand american politics i
came here and you know like
um just kept my head down um so
um
so my friends
uh
i think a lot of people within the
democratic party that knew me know me
um don't consider me like a you know an
[ __ ] they're like okay yang's doing
something that maybe i don't agree with
on this one um but we'll see where it
goes that there is this massive fear
that
the reason why i started the forward
party was so i could run for president
in 2024 and that a lot of democrats fear
that i would hive off more democratic
voters than republican voters
um that there's a concern that you know
i'm just driven by naked personal
ambition right which i mean i laugh at
because you know like certainly
um
like if my goal was to you know achieve
like the
um the most political support i could
like
one of the things you experienced too
and i joke about this is like no one
puts themselves into
the equivalent of the political
wilderness out of some you know what i
mean out of some like self grandiosity
this is really going to be the thing
because you know immediately you you
wind up
um in like a
zone where you don't have like this
infrastructure and this is one thing
that i'm very interested in working on
because i think the country needs it
very badly and i dare say that you're
you're already kind of a forerunner to
this
bridget like you you're the prototype
without even knowing it
that there should be some
independent media yeah we need our own
set of voices that are people in part
for all the people that reached out to
you and your i am politically homeless
at gmail to let them know that they're
not alone and they're not insane
[Laughter]
i've seen the the most inspiring thing
over the past couple of years for me has
been seeing a lot of people
pivoting into that space the glenn
greenwald barry weiss a lot of the
people who were maybe of the left or in
left-wing media kind of
shaking off that brand and and coming to
be more independent labeling themselves
independent
i think that a lot of people
resonate the problem that i have and i
still haven't been able to figure it out
is how do you galvanize that energy
because there's so much energy
but so much potential energy so much
potential energy and it's also just a
group of people who i think feel so
disillusioned and apathetic which was
something that i loved about your
campaign
is that
you made me feel optimistic you know
most politicians to me are so deeply
cynical i mean
i i find
i find like kamala for example to be so
phony it's offensive
and
and it's just the way i react to her on
a natural just it like affect affects me
viscerally just so and i think trump
you know i always used to say people are
so hungry for authenticity they'll
choose like an authentic [ __ ] over
somebody who they feel is just a
hillary kind of hoover a phony political
actor yeah and you broke through that
and i know you mentioned a lot of the
kind of moments you had which i loved i
loved that that first section of your
book that your story because i love the
stories
and seeing you create all that energy
um was exciting and it's it's just
how do you
how do you break through i think at the
end of the day what happens is people
want to want that but then they get
scared and they retreat to
one side or the other because they feel
like it's hopeless and they're you know
i i got to i told everybody this was the
other time i got absolutely
buried was at the election i was like
i'm not voting not voting for anyone
not for the two major parties and people
on both sides accused me of throwing the
election for whatever the you know
whatever side they were on
like your one voted california was gonna
be there yeah like it even mattered
which by the way is but they were just
like you shouldn't be saying this and
even putting this message out there and
i think people who even dare to say i'm
voting independent get so piled on by i
talked to a woman who's a
media figure who just said like hey i'm
voting third party and just got piled on
oh yeah mercilessly it's not even worth
it to to to say it and so people i don't
feel like
that's what i mean how do you galvanize
all this potential energy if people are
scared to even stand in that space and
admit that they're there
because yes you take so much or this is
the other part of it uh bridget is that
they're rational
and paying attention to politics is
depressing right so the rational thing
to do is just be like [ __ ] it like i'm
just gonna ignore it
and if i'm gonna vote third party or not
vote i'm not going to talk about it
like this is a very
uh rational set of moves
and and so the challenge and i i tell
jokes about this sometimes it's like the
challenge is to get people to join
who are by the name their nature are not
naturally joiners right
right that's my twitter bio is my tribe
is tribalist you know it's like how do
you how do you create
a
kind of center out of something that's
kind of centerless then and that is by
nature a lot of these independents they
are by definition independent so
and it's hard to i think to capture and
you see this within libertarianism
there's like such a big umbrella of
who is captured under the libertarian
umbrella and there's the more
right-leaning folks and the more
left-leaning folks and the anarchists
and i think within this kind of
politically homeless disillusioned you
have people who have wandered in from
the right but they still on principle or
even maybe on social things might lean
more right and then you have people from
the left and
if it comes down to single issues where
we're just somebody in the middle how do
you even manage to
bridge that divide even within such a
disparate group of people
yeah the the problem you're describing
has been called the mushy middle
is that how do you create
a coherent party out of the mushy middle
one group of people that have reached
out to me since i started the forward
party that i've been encouraged by
is military veterans and ex-law
enforcement who are not into trump
but who are not democrats and they're
looking around saying okay and a number
of them have reached out to me and said
i've been waiting for something like the
forward party thank you and that made me
really glad
there are a couple of consistent strains
of
uh political ideology that are attracted
to this kind of movement
people who are
principled patriotic uh don't think that
either party is working
right now
i love the people that i've
made common cause with this last number
of weeks months uh i'm a big fan of
yours bridget just thank you for this
conversation but there is something
um profound about people who've kind of
taken off the blue hat or the red hat uh
and then looked around and said oh
and in many cases by the way have to
walk through
a lot of adversity or verbal pummeling
and then that shapes you in a particular
way you're like wait what happened and
then you're on the other side of it it's
a little bit like high school
it's a lot like high school
yeah we are
very much um
a tribal
species really it's not just americans
have you read anything by jonathan
height yeah of course he's been on the
podcast
fascinating yeah that that's amazing so
john's a friend and so here was my shot
at it bridgette and we'll see if it
works
um so one of the lessons in my book was
that all politics is tribal and i took
that from john i took that from my own
experience and so you have the blue team
and the red team and they get very mad
like if if you
you know like
seem like you're helping the other team
or uh
or
unaligned and so what i i think we need
is we need more tribes
we need a new tribe i have proposed the
forward tribe
and the ideas behind the forward tribe
are around positivity
unity
solving problems fellowship grace
intolerance agreeing to disagree
uh and
um
trying to call
frankly evil on a system that is making
people hate each other it's like that
any system that is causing widespread
hate is bad
that's
and and that's where we are now uh you
know like uh the average american i mean
[ __ ] like people on twitter
are saying things every day that like no
sane person would say in real life
yeah
you're like this is like you know it's
not not a healthy environment um and
they feel
very
uh
[Music]
very virtuous in doing it you know they
feel like they're fighting for something
um so i was joking with someone on tv
it's like i want to be like like the
soothing wet blanket for the country
like i've set my
my voice on soothing
so
this is
the hope for the forward tribe is that
we can be the sense talkers
to the rest of the country
and give people a
banner that they can
you know
wave
and feel good about
do you have a lot of bernie bro
supporters i'm not sure to be honest
with you yeah um like uh certainly there
was a lot of overlap between the yang
gang and bernie bros i haven't really
gotten a sense of um
whether the forward party consists of
uh the same group or a different group
um
yeah well we'll find out over time i
hope so if you're a bernie bro listening
to this
yang loves you yang was a bernie bro
2016.
yeah i think that
it's interesting too because you seem to
strike chords with you know ubi and
maybe an idea of more socialism
and
also even though that's a dirty word or
whatever but it has this kind of
feel about more stronger social networks
and and help and support
and also i love that you don't abandon
patriotism because that was one of the
things that kind of pushed me center
like i don't hate this country i've
traveled all over the world and every
time i come back to america for all of
its flaws i'm like i am so lucky to live
in this country i really was lucky to be
born here i always say i think america's
biggest problem is that americans don't
get out of america enough they just
don't see
and i don't mean like your
your college trip to europe i mean like
travel put a backpack on go see parts of
the world that are hard and
and ride a bus through the south of
india maybe don't do that but i did that
and
see
see other places and
how
the opportunity that we have i married
my first marriage was to a guy from
belarus and so i was exposed firsthand
to
just what he went through in his
childhood what he had to do he came to
america knowing no english and managed
to like build a whole life i'm like
where else can you do that you know and
and get a degree and have multiple
properties now and
ex two ex-wives
this is an american dream
you did it
you married two american women you did
it
i'm probably not going on number three
for all i know and it it's just i don't
know i i really i can't my grandparents
were
very patriotic my grandfather fought in
world war ii they were in pearl harbor
when it was bombed it
they just grew we were grown up with an
enormous sense of gratitude for the
country that we lived in and so yes
obviously we have our flaws and
i'm grateful that you don't kind of
throw that baby out with the bathwater
because i think on the left there's a
lot of pressure to do that
oh gosh no i mean i'm the child of
immigrants and my parents came here for
a better life for
me and my brother primarily and it's
worked
uh and i'm a parent now and like i
want my kids to grow up in a country
that
they're excited about so i love this
country dearly
i think that should be the starting
point really that could be one aspect of
the forward party that's look we have
problems for sure and oh by the way
one of the problems is we have this
messed up duopoly that's
like turning us against each other
but
you have to
appreciate everything that makes this
country
uh special because
even with all of our problems there are
still hundreds of millions of people
that would
uh move here in the blink of an eye if
they had the chance
[Music]
what was it about the new york race
that you ran
that felt so different about your
um presidential campaign to me just
observing it oh no they were very
different i mean my presidential
campaign uh it was a race against
um being ignored
right so much of it was born of me
personally like every
idea every policy i'd written a book
before i was a public figure you know
like that there was something very
organic and natural
and light about it and then the new york
mayoral race
i came in as a front-runner and a
national figure and so the entire thing
was
uh just surviving uh press attacks every
single day so there there wasn't a lot
of
there was a lot of positivity to be had
it was also winter for a lot of it it
was coved yeah um
there weren't in person events for a lot
of it so like the way you connect with
people was all through this
uh fun house mirror of the press
uh
so that it was a very different dynamic
and a different energy and the the truth
of it is that new york city at the time
uh was really hurting yeah it's like if
you imagine
new york city
covid winter 2021 pre-vaccines i mean
that that was the context of the race
yeah that was a dark time in that city
and
it felt um it definitely felt like the
press was
very
um mean to you
you're like looking for the word i know
um they were not
charitable really it seemed like
the attacks were more
personal
it felt it just felt different although
you do say in in your book and it was
one of my questions that i had that the
national media initially presented you
as the internet candidate which i kind
of understand or the preferred candidate
of the alt-right why do you think that
was that they presented you that way
i do not know to this day um i think
there were a couple of uh maybe forums
or something where some stuff bubbled up
from um but
it was a very strange characterization
and
um well like i was mystified by it i
didn't take it very seriously because i
just thought it was so weird
[Laughter]
that my team
um was like oh you know you should
really uh you know try and get in front
of this and i was like no one's gonna
think that it doesn't make any sense
it doesn't
do you think that the problems i mean i
i feel like i get
i have
i have a hard time finding optimism
lately you're one of the few
places i turn when i'm feeling really
down oh that means so much to me
bridgette i'll go to your twitter feed
and be like i know this will be positive
even if it's a lie no
even if his optimism is
is
i've got this very solid look on my face
while i'm crafting those optimistic
tweets i'm like
what [ __ ] am i gonna put out into
the twitter sphere now
no i don't know
that you're like i mean even
that i'm lying to myself that it's
there's reason to be optimistic well
here's the thing bridgette i mean like
and this is one of the the strange
tensions in my brief political existence
so i ran for president on a very
optimistic idea of universal basic
income but it was built on a very
negative case which is oh by the way
ai's coming and it's going to blast away
like a ton of jobs and we already did it
to those guys we're going to do it to
you too eventually
um so that there's like a real
um you know juxtaposition or it's like
and the other thing is someone said to
me it's like hey yang you can present
some very distressing [ __ ] in a
matter-of-fact way that doesn't make me
you know super sad and i'm like oh good
well you know this is um so
the situation right now is
awful
uh our political landscape
terrible like generationally bad
um and so it's not like i'm unmindful of
these things i mean the fact is if i
thought that things were going to go
well
i would be doing something else right
you know what i mean
like so i'm very cognizant of just how
knee deep and [ __ ] we are and the and
the shit's you know threatening to go
well above knee level
right
but but now i'm in a position where
maybe i can
help maybe i can contribute something
positive i see a path
and it does consist of what you're
describing with this look politically
homeless
yeah like potential energy let's just
come together raise our hands say look
um we
want something different
uh and the forward party is a way to
achieve something different at a minimum
it's a way to say get off my back i'm
not donating to either of your
candidates
[Laughter]
i'm just going to
make my home over here
and try and fight for a process where
new parties can emerge
do you is does anything
make you reconsider ubi would anything
make you reconsider like did the labor
market's reaction to extended payouts
over the pandemic
did any of that make you reconsider it
or is there anything that would make you
reconsider it
oh i'm a evidence driven
uh guy so you know like i'm always open
to new information
i do think though that you have to
segment the cash release into different
buckets uh the child tax credit
pure good you know 442 economists are
like we should do this forever yeah the
cash relief checks in my opinion
good you know like helped bail a lot of
people out the part that we can all take
legitimate issue with in my opinion was
the enhanced unemployment benefits right
because in those
situations we actually tied the money to
not having a job and not working right
and i talked to a number of people who
said look i'm getting paid 85 of what i
was gonna get paid if i was working so
i'm not going to look for a job until
these benefits run out yeah and i looked
at that and said makes perfect sense you
know like we we should not be tying
money to things that disincentivize
someone um taking a job if that's what
they want and oh by the way this
predates
uh the pandemic when i was in iowa
talking to a waitress she would say to
me look i want to work part-time but if
i do it's going to reduce my benefits
like there are so many people that are
in versions of that situation all the
time because our programs are structured
very very punitively and poorly yeah you
know like anyone who looked at that
would be like that woman should work
part-time and i don't care if she keeps
getting her money like like that the the
money
is not being channeled in the right ways
one of the questions my audience had for
you i did a little asking questions
within my community and
a lot of stuff about ubi obviously but
one that i loved was um
please ask what financial literacy
programs he recommends for the general
public
without this knowledge no amount of
guaranteed income produces outcomes
promised from ubi would the idea of ubi
or if you got ubi would it come with
some kind of
financial literacy or and or even
any and i mean i learned nothing about
any of this when i was growing up i
learned everything the hard way i went
bankrupt when i was 27 because i started
my company and knew nothing
and
i didn't know anything about budgeting
money or any i had no financial literacy
i'm still i still feel like i i have
like a very come on do you have any
accounts receivable 90 day savings
account i still have i still have like
that the i always joke that i'm
basically still like a high schooler i'm
just paying rent now
i'm like
almost a grown-up almost
but i'm not alone you know like that
idea of like rich dad poor dad is so
true i had so many rich friends and they
were talking about money and discussing
stocks and all of these things
when
when i was a teenager you know they were
having these conversations about this
stuff and they were talking to their
parents about it and i never i didn't
learn any of that stuff
but so we should be teaching financial
literacy at the grade school level um
the the
um the least we can do is give them some
fake money and then have them do various
things and then reward people who do
something you know prudent with the fake
money ideally you'd have some real money
and one of the things i remember vividly
about being a teenager is that you know
someone tried to teach me some [ __ ]
about money and it just went in one year
out one out the other
until i actually had some real money
which was you know like a number of
years later and then it was like what do
i do
and so i remember i bought some styling
like citibank or verizon and then it
went down
you know 10 bucks or 20 bucks it was
like a free trade or something like one
of those starter accounts
and then um and then it going up or down
20 was was hypnotizing and i would just
like sit there and like
watch it
um
so
we need to try and get people more
exposure uh earlier um along those lines
and i love rich dad poor dad as a book
uh you know the main principle of that
book is just pay yourself first and you
think oh what the hell does that mean
and you're like oh am i supposed to pay
down this pay down that like the big
principle of paying yourself first i
thought it's really powerful i mean hell
i think that books sold 10 gazillion
copies
good job asian dude
oh he's like you know there's a
it's
an asian author i think his name's
robert yeah no
so we should 100 be teaching people at
the high school level my vision
bridget was everyone gets taught
financial literacy in high school and
then you start getting a basic income uh
your senior years when most people turn
18. oh by the way we also send you to
another part of the country for a month
live with another family so you have a
little bit of exposure and you don't
think of people in another area as
uh like fly over country et cetera yeah
or coastal
it's like oh i actually spent time there
and they were like perfectly nice
um
and then you have some real money a
couple bucks to rub together and then
any lesson i try and teach you will
become real very quickly that was the
ideal progression for me
can we still pull that off i mean i'd
like to i'd like to try
one of the other questions i liked and
it's this goes back to your point about
how there's so many
things that are disincentive
in in the way our system is structured
what are ways in which we can prove
improved social safety nets provided by
the government for instance if someone
has
ssidi you can't own certain types of
property and this could cause problems
for disabled people who want to do
something like own an affordable home
but are still in need of that
supplemental income how would ubi differ
from what we already have and how would
it be similar
so the the benefit systems that we have
right now are difficult to access
they're punitive they act like they
don't trust you at all
and the people that i know who are
receiving these benefits live in fear of
losing them because they're going to
screw up a filing or do something wrong
there's a woman who's getting disability
benefits who was afraid to volunteer at
her church because
she was
uh afraid someone was going to see her
volunteer and then say you're
able-bodied and then oh wow disability
awareness that's the kind of thing that
people live with right um so
my in my
ideal world we would not be attaching
negative conditions to any of these
payments if you're getting a social
security disability like i actually did
not know you couldn't own something
that's horrifying to me
that would make no sense at all but by
the way we have this array of
bureaucratic requirements and then an
army of people kind of overlooking them
and then
millions of americans being subject to
these arcane rules and then you have to
go and you like stand in line and go to
these offices
it's the worst you know it it's because
we're programmed for scarcity
and mistrust
and punishing people who quote unquote
need help um like we need to reverse
that and say look you're an american
you're a citizen we're wealthy here's a
thousand bucks you know don't sweat it
[Laughter]
and oh by the way we believe in you and
we trust you and then you can turn to
your kids and be like hey you're an
american it's [ __ ] awesome yeah you
know you're getting money when when
you're a senior
uh you know maybe take a year
uh learn a few lessons and then you know
maybe go to college if you want or don't
go to college you know maybe like learn
to trade do something else like we
shouldn't be presenting college as the
end all be all because it's really not
[Music]
do you
worry that giving people money
as you were mentioning tying kind of the
unemployment that people were getting
and we saw this in california out here
as well will it
hurt i mean i've been traveling a lot
and seeing these labor shortages like in
in real time
um
do you worry that if people get the ubi
then we'll we'll have like a society
that just kind of quits working
well you know i i think a thousand bucks
a month is like uh you know not enough
to exactly live large
so that's what i was suggesting
um
i i'm someone who thinks that
working is a positive thing and that
getting more people
uh
into
environments where they're excited to
work is the goal
one thing that does make me sad is that
if you look at our labor participation
rate it's low and it's been declining
for years and years and years so when
people look up and say hey
yang ubi it's gonna keep people from
working and you look up be like hey look
around you i mean we've been on this
track for
years and years and years and the labor
market's falling apart like it like last
i checked it was in the low 60s
60s in terms of percentage of people
working it's comparable to el salvador
or the ukraine and that's right now
so at this point the horse is out of the
barn the horse is like running around
why do you think that is or what do they
attribute that to
i mean uh there are a lot of
explanations i i think that we've been
going through this economic
transformation and it's kicking more and
more people to the curb
and you're not reckoning with it
appropriately um you're also seeing
substance abuse go up depression go up
like like people are dropping out and
right now i do want to say like this
pandemic is miserable it's a very tough
time people are leaving jobs because
they've just had it they burnt out i you
know i understand and get that too uh i
think there are a lot of factors right
now
but if you look at the last number of
years uh we're we're anomalously low
across developed countries and i think
that's driving a lot of the
problems um both economically and
politically
yeah one of the things that i really
love that you address is healthcare and
i i don't understand why one party
doesn't just run on that because it
seems like something that every person
in america struggles with no matter
which side of the aisle they're on
and it affects people
trying to navigate the healthcare system
or even there's just no transparency it
drives me insane our system is the worst
it is
it's crazy because we have great
medicine you know there's i i've been
there's so many things that are good we
have great doctors we have great
medicine but the the way you have to
navigate the system and the different
obviously
different levels of that system
depending on where you fall economically
are they're so different i was
volunteering with the elderly for
pre-pandemic
and i never really thought very much
about retirement because i thought well
i thought i'd be dead by 27 a and b it's
just you know living paycheck to
paycheck you're like oh figure that out
when i get there
and it never occurred to me and then i
was
there was a man that i would volunteer
with and he was in a very like a state
housing kind of
and then a woman who was very good with
her money and worked in the postal
system and she but she'd saved and was
ready for retirement and
the level of difference in their care
was
so crazily different
like it made me panic i was like oh crap
oh no i gotta be like her
i at least better start saving right now
because
it was so crazily i mean no you couldn't
even compare the two
um
and i just that is that bums me out you
know seeing
seeing the circumstances that
that some people are in just because
they
i don't know
yeah it's gonna be a lot of people too
and i agree with you that
uh
most of us agree on overhauling the
healthcare system um this is one of the
corruptions of the duopoly in my opinion
where and thank god for bernie sanders
just running on medicare for all and
then like breaking
the seal we're gonna bring the glass
ceiling yeah
we should do that
um because
to me it's common sense that we should
be heading in that direction
uh
and most americans agree i mean now more
than ever too you look up
like tying
health care to employment makes less and
less sense now
yeah it never made sense to me i i
always had private health care because i
was a freelancer so i i just i it never
made sense it's actually a leftover from
world war ii when there were pay caps
and uh companies started tacking on
health care as an incentive to work for
them and then we got stuck with that
bizarro system it never made sense
uh that that that's actually in some
ways a microcosm of what we're dealing
with bridget is that something gets
developed in american life and it
doesn't make sense but we're kind of
stuck with it
i'm going to suggest the duopoly is that
too it's like this duopoly the founders
did not intend political parties they
certainly didn't attend two political
parties
and then they came into existence
decades later and they don't make sense
but everyone's like no no you're stuck
with it it's like well do you think
things are working well right now no no
no but you're stuck with it because the
other guys
i've been told that our system was
structured this way so i don't know i
don't and i don't know enough to argue
one or the other because you could
definitely call [ __ ] on that
like the like george washington's
farewell speech was like political
parties bad john adams wrote in 1780 two
parties would be an evil
you know
like
the republican party doesn't even exist
until
like the 1850s and 60s
like all the shit's made up yeah
it seems like it fuels this whole media
complex too that we just can't break out
they need each other so badly and it's
so hard to break outside of you and me
bridgette independent media
political thinking yeah a shelter for
the homeless the forward party it's not
left or right may it be a shelter for
you all and uh shield you from the
partisan appeals uh yeah
and the anger and rancor and the the
dismay and the divisiveness
yeah it's definitely
i i hope you know i have a lot of
i try to maintain that optimism i i do i
really do even though i see everyone
getting hyper-polarized and radicalized
and like
increasingly the column i wrote
yesterday was all about i mean i really
have nothing to offer but my own
confusion but just
how
i feel like
and i don't know if this is a uh
if it's like a a bug or if it's a
feature
is that i the i just feel
broken down by everything being
politicized everything
and it's just broken me down to the
point where i don't know what to believe
i have no faith in any institutions i
have no faith in any authority i have no
faith in
my local government to take care of my
own safety i'm in california i have no i
have
zero respect for any of the like nancy
pelosi's or the
all these politicians who have just
enriched themselves that's another thing
i don't understand how can you how is
there not and like
trading laws for politicians
it seems like something that should not
be allowed how is nancy pelosi so rich i
don't understand you're like you're
supposed to be a public servant it
doesn't feel like anybody's serving the
people it feels like they're serving
corporations i feel like the banking
system is totally screwed i mean i don't
i don't know and so i can only imagine i
don't know how the average american
family is even paying for groceries
right now i just
i i stay up at night stare at the
ceiling you know like how how do you
even begin
to fix this and like you said all these
like the 100 i'm a like as i mentioned a
recovering
in recovery and that hundred thousand
overdoses i i was so upset for days just
that that number that could have been
yes me or many of the people that i know
and that seems like a symptom of all of
the things going on not just the
pandemic this was happening before the
pandemic
yeah 100
and so yeah there's i i don't know do we
have to like hit some crazy rock bottom
to find our way out or are we at rock
bottom and just don't know it
uh i think that things are going to get
very rough uh over the next several
years that's what jonathan i said
he was like it's gonna be really bad for
ten years and it's like great
it's gonna be rocky
going for a while
and then hopefully we'll no maybe we'll
make it a little bit less rocky and
maybe we'll be able to build something
positive um certainly
jonathan is going to be a big part of
that i know you will too bridget
hopefully i will be
and yeah we'll we'll keep building the
tribe uh and give people
a place to belong um you've done that
for a lot of people already and uh you
beat me to it i'm i'm grateful to you
and i've really enjoyed getting to know
you a bit better yeah i want to ask you
the same two questions i ask everyone at
the end of my podcast
what is your biggest defect of character
my biggest defect of character is that i
get very very hard on myself at times
like i don't enjoy any success
i you know i think when i was a kid i
used to joke about how if i got an a
test i'd feel good for like 30 seconds
and then i'd feel this emptiness
thereafter maybe it's um an immigrant
thing
but i think that's my biggest character
defect it sometimes makes me
not a great
uh husband
uh father partner you have to let it
land that's what people always tell me
you've got to celebrate because i'm i'm
very similar you have to celebrate your
wins and all this stuff i heard a
podcast with i forget who it was but he
said the same thing similar thing
and he said that um
it was the day his first book came out
and he's like he booked a like
maintenance on his car and his wife was
like what are you doing it's your first
book and he's like just another day babe
i'm going to the mechanic to get my car
fixed and i really identified with that
it's like
she was like you're allowed to be
excited and give yourself credit for
stuff and
and let things land as my therapist says
what is yours
yeah
what's your um biggest asset other than
your just
amazing optimism that i turned to for
strength
oh thank you bridget
um
my greatest asset is that for some
reason
good people
want to work with me slash put up with
me
like there are so many amazing people
that
decided to make my campaign their own
uh the first person i think of um is my
wife evelyn who really does put up with
a lot
uh
there have been
so many people that have made
me successful that don't get the kind of
credit that they deserve uh you know
it's just unfortunate like an
unfortunate feature of um the way credit
gets assigned
where it's like oh it must have been uh
yang when you know there are a lot of
people
um
making it happen so that's like my
greatest asset is that i i'll say this
about myself i just want [ __ ] to work
and i don't care about
who did what or or how and i think that
there are good people that are attracted
to that where they're like okay
if i want to do my best work yang will
be into that and yang like doesn't care
about credit he doesn't care about
uh
glory uh he's all about just trying to
accomplish goals that's i think maybe
the best thing about me and
that that's
that's definitely something that i'm
drawn to your kind of practical
application of trying to make society
better
instead of just all of the rhetoric and
nonsense you definitely cut through that
one question i did have is the forward
party
something are you planning on running in
2024 or is it just you might you're just
trying to start a party and then
maybe find someone else to run is that
or is there a plan for it
so the ford party's short-term goals are
to try and transition a number of states
to open primaries so it's not just you
know democrats or republicans that are
able to vote
and that has to happen in 2022 for us to
just take shots at it
um the plan in 2024
is tbd
i'm not being kawaii it's just where we
have to see what happened in 2022 we
have to see what the landscape looks
like yeah um i i will suggest that i
think that the country could use an
alternative
uh to
the two major parties and if it's not me
it would be
someone hopefully that i'm excited about
um
supporting
uh but i'm open to doing whatever that
includes running it includes not running
and supporting someone else
uh
it's like what i said before it's like
uh you know you just have to try and
figure out the best way to accomplish
your goals
but
i'm
i can visualize right now the uh
probably biden trump rematch or the oh
god
or the kamala trump uh oh god and and i
think if you guys
i i i would say a solid 20 to 25 percent
of americans in that situation would
look around and be like what are my
other choices what are my other choices
if you had someone credible they'd be
like all right
let's head this direction yeah
and one last question what can the
average person do who might be
interested in helping you or supporting
your ideas or helping to build this
because one of the things that i have
noticed is the lack of infrastructure
like you mentioned for that third party
um what can somebody do locally to try
and help that process along
well
the best thing you can do is go to
forwardparty.com uh sign up we have
volunteer opportunities everywhere you
can start your local chapter it could be
at your school it could be in your town
uh you know you could wind up with like
a local
town official who's a foreign which has
already happened in
pennsylvania so super grateful
but yeah go to forwardparty.com sign up
uh you can donate five bucks uh it's not
about the money it's just about raising
your hand and saying
we need something better than what we're
getting right now yeah and if we get
enough americans and start this wave we
can create a real alternative to the
duopoly that right now is not serving
the people at all
there are dozens of us
dozens of us dozens of millions who meet
bridgette dozens of millions but yeah
wait what does that quote from the
dozens of it's
that's the show that i just again you
arrest development when i need to feel
just some positivity or laugh that show
is just so brilliant i'll just watch the
first three seasons on repeat but that
episode's one of my favorites where he's
like there are dozens of us
it's my favorite guest i'll use it i
like it weekly
because there are dozens of millions of
us
i really appreciate i hope this is not
our last time talking because i still
want to talk to you about so much more
and i know that
we occupy such a
um similar
you know where the mushy metal or the
mushy center in this landscape and
i really do appreciate your voice your
optimism your ideas i just appreciate
that if nothing else you're trying
something different at least you're
trying to break through and do something
different and
i know i'm not alone so i where can
everyone find you other than forward
party where where you just mentioned to
go just online yeah andrew yang on most
social media
platforms as bridget just said i'm
pretty upbeat on them so if you need to
pick me up
[Laughter]
i'm not kidding like when i'm really in
the despair and i see the back and forth
or there's like and you know the
weirdest thing about being an
independent is when
you are
and maybe this has happened to you but
you'll something a news story will break
and it's one of the ones where everyone
retreats to their their tribe and it's
like living into america simultaneously
you're watching this
i think scott adams always says to
america's one screen you know it's just
a very strange surreal feeling
where you're like i don't belong in
either of these movies
i'm so alone we're going to create our
own movie bridgette you can write the
script i love it well thank you so much
for your time and
i will be talking to you more
you too check out bridgette fantasy
where can people find you bridget oh
everybody can find me at bridget fettucy
on pretty much all the social medias and
if you go to fettucy.com we have a
little um it's like our center for the
politically homeless um and it's
just
it's like a little paywall place where
we all have actually really cool
conversations and post
recipes
it's it's like the nicest place it's an
oasis for me online it's really actually
quite remarkable
that sounds delightful
uh i think you're gonna get some new
members fantasy.com no thank you
[Music]
you